thank you to all the organizers for
having me uh here today
let's see i gotta start up the other
so i am giving a powerpoint presentation
frank my apologies
you can let me know at the end if i if i
satisfy that
so uh
before i get to talking about the the
content i just want to acknowledge that
there's a lot of collaborators that have
participated in this work with me
uh the main ones are andrew simazi
at notre dame we've been working
together since
the late 80s and then
john howenstein and dan bates
a newer this includes uh the bertino
software development which you may have
heard of i'll mention it a little today
and a more recent thing is is
laser just died
more recent thing is burtini real
software
which includes these guys plus also
daniel brake and winry howe dan's here
and we'll talk about uh bertini real
more
at the end of today
and then i'll i'll speak a little bit
about a couple application areas and the
mechanism design work is is with some
mechanical engineers at university of
dayton and sphere packing work is with
miranda home sir phone at
nyu
well it might be too many things to
handle
thank you though
okay
a quick outline uh the uh start with a
little motivation then i'll give a
little a brief background in numerical
algebraic geometry a lot of people here
have had some exposure to it already
some more recent work on intersection of
algebraic sets and and just a little bit
about what we're doing with real
algebraic sets i'm going to let daniel
talk mostly about that today
and then
these application areas
so motivation
my motivation for getting into
algebraic geometry is kinematics and
robotics and here's an example of
some of the work i've participated in
this is robonaut 2.
it's a anthropomorphic robot with 42
degrees of freedom it's up on the
international space station it's been up
there three years now so this was a fun
project to be involved in
you can see
how he's situated uh in the space
station with what we call a task board
here a bunch of switches and cables to
connect and and things to experiment to
see what a dexterous robot can do
in
august
nasa sent up a leg module so this
what we built was from the waist up
and they've now sent up legs which is a
nice thing you can do with a robot you
can't do with an astronauts in his legs
up later
and uh so sometime i think it'll
probably take till next year till they
you know
you send things up when you can and then
you get them out and use them when when
they're on the schedule so sometime next
year he'll be
wandering around the space station
so that's kind of cool but let's
let's look inside of robonaut a little
bit
this is a it's a cad drawing of the
forearm and hand the hand has 12 degrees
of freedom and you have to actuate those
you can't put all these motors in the
hand itself so just like you and i the
motors are back here in the forearm and
tendons go out to the fingers and and
actuate them
tendons can only pull they can't push
you can't push a rope as the saying goes
so you have to actually have more
tendons than degrees of freedom out here
so with 12 degrees of freedom i believe
there's 16 different tendons coming out
they all have to pass through this wrist
so you want to keep the wrist open
and here is a an actual photograph with
the covers taken off of the robonaut
wrist this is the hand the gold part
this is the forearm is over here and you
can see all these tendons and their
conduits going through the opening
so
we needed this
this wrist with an open structure it has
a pitch axis goes like this a yaw axis
goes like this and then it has
these what i call push-pull links on the
outside and it makes a closed chain
mechanism that you can now
move with two degrees of freedom and
have it all open for the tendons to come
through so where's the polynomials in
this
well
i've got a motor that drives
this little ball forward and backwards
another one up here
and then i want to know the relationship
between the translations here and the
rotations here so you form up a system
of equations if you write it in the
sines and cosines of the angles
it's all polynomial you put in sine
squared plus cosine squared equals one
you're good it's a polynomial system and
then you can look at it
uh two ways one is
if uh if you put in the
slider values you'd like to solve for
the angles
that's uh the forward problem the
inverse problem is uh you put in the the
outputs the angles and you want to solve
for the
or the slider values and so
depending on which way you go you have
either four solutions or eight solutions
that's not uh
by far
one of the it's it's one of the simpler
problems that we've solved in the
kinematics arena but this thought is
it's a fun one to show because it's uh
it's
you got the photograph there and it's on
robonaut itself here's a here's a
picture
a diagram that shows
from a
a bigger picture perspective what what
you can face in kinematics so
in the center here i have what i call
the the mechanism space
and
if i have a system
i'll call it f of x and p
so
this would be like all the joint angles
and the uh the
the output space
coordinates
and then this
would be the parameters
the mechanism so if we go back
here what are the parameters it would be
where where is this
sliding line in the coordinate frame of
the forearm where is the other one so
the the physical dimensions of the
device that you built but i can
characterize
all devices of this type
that have two sliders two push pull
links and so on and in one system and
parameterized by those geometric things
so now if i look at v of f
that's what i mean by m
in the middle of this diagram so it
encodes
the whole family
of
let's say robonaut risk types okay
so now i have
just a simple projection to pull out the
design parameters
just pull out p
but i also have these
polynomial maps to the outputs and to
the inputs and we'd like to move around
in this communicative diagram so when i
talk about forward kinematics it means
you start down here
with a device of a certain design so i
know the parameters and i'm giving you
the inputs
i'd like to tell you to tell me what my
output is
oh that's kind of a symmetric problem is
i
give you also the design but now i'm
telling you what output i want from it
tell me what input so how how far should
i turn
the motors that drive the links to get
the output that you want
but then there's other problems
one is
you start with the design parameters and
you ask what's the whole set of outputs
i might get that's called workspace
analysis i'm not worrying about what
input it takes to get to them i just
want to know the whole whole space and
then
some of the hardest problems go this way
and i'm actually
faking this a little bit
uh you want to start with the outputs
you want to achieve and arrive at the
design parameters of a mechanism that
will give you those outputs or that
output space
and the reason i say i'm cheating a
little bit
is typically i have to give multiple
sets of outputs that i'm trying to get
so it's really a cross product of a
bunch of these
that go that way so it's not just a map
from output to to parameters and i'm
going to talk a little bit about one of
these problems those tend to be
hard because when you start taking cross
products of this
things get big
so another motivation is sphere packings
is it cross products because of the the
extra joints is that
no what is what it is is if
and i'll get to this later suppose let's
take a simple mechanism this is called a
four bar linkage
this means these points are fixed in
space
but these are our rotational joints
and when you turn a joint here this this
point up here will make some curve
turns out it's a sixth degree
curve
and what i might say is i'd like you to
design a four bar that can go through
certain can interpolate certain points
so the cross product comes up from
saying
this the solution to the system has to
go through this point and now it has to
go through this one so there's a copy of
the system for each
point you want to go through
now this is another problem area i've
been working on a little called
sphere packing and the question is
how do microspheres cluster
this is
work
came out of
harvard
vinnie monaharan is a physicist mike
brenner is a is a mathematician arcus
did her phd on this
and uh 2011
and uh
vinnie is actually doing the experiments
he has these uh micro uh
wells with with
i don't know if it's water or some other
fluid he puts them the micro beads in
they let some cluster he takes x-ray
uh
images of them and then figures out how
they actually cluster together so that's
like the experimental side the math side
is to try to predict
how they'll cluster together so when
these spheres come in contact
there they have a
a surface adhesion they'll stick to each
other and they'll
keep moving if there's any degrees of
freedom they'll tend to move until they
make another contact and eventually you
end up with a rigid cluster
so the question is what are the rigid
clusters that you can make so if you
have six spheres
you'll make uh uh essentially an octagon
where each sphere is at the center of
one of the vertices the centers of the
spheres are at the vertices of an
octagon as you move up
you get more and more possibilities it
starts to explode
and this is
just
what they call the table of new seeds
these are the the ones
that are not
um
that you can't get just by putting like
tetrahedra together okay
i'll explain that a little bit more
but the point is each sphere of the
sphere contact is a distance constraint
and so the this
project of of predicting all the
different ways they can cluster comes
down to enumerating the possible
adjacency graphs how can different
which spheres contact which other
spheres and then for each of these
there's a system of quadratic
polynomials to solve because it's a
distance constraint and that's uh you
know a quadrant
all right so that's a little motivation
let's uh let's get into numerical
algebraic geometry
so i
some people have seen a lot of this
before other people i i'm assuming
there's some people that haven't seen it
before so i'm gonna give you a quick
ramp up into numerical algebraic
geometry
so let's say i want to find all the
isolated solutions to a polynomial
system f that's a map from c n to c n so
the same number of equations as uh
as unknowns
and what's the approach
we're going to cast
f of x as a member of some parameterized
family of systems so this looks like
what i i drew for the for the robot we
always these kind of things arrive
naturally but this
process is is usually making up a
a family that's convenient at our
convenience
where
one member of the family is the system
we want to solve so here my parameter
space
it looks like maybe it's just a one
parameter space you know the the real
and the imaginary part of the one
parameter and for one value here is the
system i want to solve
now i'm going to solve this for a
generic member of the family so it's
some other p1 i'm going to solve it and
i'm going to have some set of isolated
solutions i'll call s
somewhere in this parameter space i
don't know where but probably there's
exceptional points where the number of
this is a generic number its
solution number of solutions is the same
almost everywhere in the parameter space
but they'll be places where the number
of isolated solutions can fall you hit
singularities and so on
so there's some non-generic parameter
points
so the game is to find
a general path that avoids
the non-generic points
and then you just track
a homotope just put that path in here
you move through parameter space you
track the solution sets from the s
solutions that you know at p1 to the
solutions at p naught and that's what
continuation is
every everything we do
comes down to some kind of game of this
form
it
so
a few things to note first of all the
non-generic set
it's
complex code dimension one so it's real
code dimension is two
that means that a randomized path
is general
for t in zero to one with probability
one
so i don't know where the non-generic
points are but if i just randomize the
path i take the probability of hitting
them is zero
and that's what we depend on with
probability one algorithm
so the key to this whole thing is how do
i pick this family that has a generic p1
that i can solve that easily enough
and also
i would prefer to have the number of
solutions in this in this family as
small as possible it'd be great if it
had the same number of solutions as my
target it might have more okay so
finding a family that's
it seems like solving here would be just
as hard as solving here how does this
thing get off the ground well the
easiest way to to show that is the
original
homotopy that satisfies these conditions
this is uh what we call the total degree
homo-topi it's just it's sort of the
simplest way to go
and it's been around since i think
garcia and xango did it in 1977
if i remember right so
what do you do you take for each
polynomial in the target system it has
some degree
you match it with
a harmonic polynomial in just one
variable
with that same degree and you just
line all those up well what's the
solution to this start system it's just
the roots of unity in each one of these
all possible combinations so you have
the product of the degrees number of
solutions here
and by bizoo's theorem that's the
maximum possible so this is a generic
problem in the family and so now i just
have to connect it up to the target with
the general path and it's easy to show
that if you just do what we call a
linear homotope
1 minus t here
and gamma t here where gamma's random
complex
that
this is a probability one algorithm in
other words that just putting this one
random complex number here is enough to
ensure
that you have a
zero probability of hitting the
non-generic points
so let's uh let's up our game a little
bit
problem two
now i have a polynomial system with the
number of equations and unknowns not
necessarily equal
and i'd like to find the whole
v of f the all the points
in the in cn that satisfy that
well what does that mean when the
dimension is bigger than zero i mean
we're working on a computer i can't list
it's it's on the complexes i can't list
out all the solutions what what does it
mean to give you the solution set well
instead of
if it's isolated
points is all you want i can list
approximations to all the isolated
points but for for a
higher dimensional thing what i'm going
to give you instead is what we call a
witness set
so
and in fact what we'd like to do is have
one witness set for each of the
irreducible components of the variety
what what by setting this is our goal we
can reduce problem two to several
instances of problem one
so we're just looking for isolated
points that satisfy the conditions of
the witness set so what is a witness set
it's a it's a triple so algebraic set a
a witness set for it consists of three
things
f is a polynomial system such that a is
an irreducible component of v of f
so in a lot of times we start with f but
uh
later
we oftentimes have a a derived f that
came from some other source in the
beginning
so we need that
we need l is a generic
linear space of complementary dimension
to a
and then the the third element is what
we call the witness point set it's the
intersections of l with a so if a is
degree
d we're going to get d points in l
intersect a because l is a generic
linear space how do you get a generic
linear space you take linear equations
and you pick the coefficients with a
random number generator and
again with probability one that's going
to be generic
so
that's my introduction to numerical
algebraic geometry
what we've got in this burtini package
we've got
path tracking that has
adaptive precision so when you deal with
high degree systems
you can get ill conditioning we expand
the digits to make sure that we can are
still computing
meaningful things
and
singular in games if we head to a
singularity
if if your target is not generic some of
the paths will become singular at the
end but you know where it's happening so
you can take a special procedure to to
solve for the singular endpoints
we can do various
versions of zero dimensional solving we
can do positive dimensional sets and the
irreducible decomposition which means
producing a witness set for each
irreducible component of the variety we
can do things like membership tests and
intersection and i'm going to talk a
little bit more about intersection so
this is uh the bertini package we first
released it in 2008 so it's been around
a little while now
it's now open source and we continue to
update it
so i encourage you to uh
to look it up and give it a try
and if you want more
background than what i just gave you
there's a couple books now
and
let's talk about intersections
now this is the first dense slide in
here but let's pick it apart a little
bit so suppose i want to compute a
intersect b
well i'm in this world of numerical
algebraic geometry so what how do i even
give you a and b i'm going to give you a
witness set for each so i've got a a
system of polynomials a linear space and
a set of witness points okay
and i have one of those for a and one of
those for b
you might one way you might try to
compute a intersect b is just to take f
a and f b
stack them up together
and solve for the irreducible components
that seems good but it doesn't always
suffice and here's the easy counter
example suppose a and b
are do two components in the same system
in other words f a and f b are the same
so
you
if you did the irreducible components of
this
you would get a out as a component you
could b out as a component you wouldn't
get their intersection it's not an
irreducible component in there so what
what can you do
uh
i'll tell you what you can do in a
second but i also want to point out that
even when this suffices
so that the thing you're looking for is
an irreducible component of the stacked
system
that going at it that way could be very
wasteful because suppose
v of f of a has many irreducible
components besides a if i just stack
these up and do the irreducible
decomposition
i'll get the intersection of all those
different components with b
and i'm only looking for one of them
okay so you don't want to go at it that
way
so
how can we target a intersect b directly
and the uh the key maneuver is
if a and b are both living and say cn
instead of working in cn i'm going to
work in
c2n cn cross cn
i'm going to
in there i have a cross b
and then i'm going to intersect that
with what we call the diagonal
if x is in a y is in b and i solve x
minus y equals 0 then i'll have the
intersection
so
this is uh
now 10 years ago that we first put this
this forward
the interesting thing is and something
we didn't fully
appreciate back then is that all this
gives you is witness points
and if
you have a case where stacking a and b
together doesn't suffice i don't have a
witness set yet because i don't have
a
system that this intersection is an
irreducible component of and i've got to
construct that now
so how can we do that so we have this
thing that we call isosingular deflation
that
i don't want to go into the detail
but
it can start from the witness set
and get up
you can start from the witness points
and get me a witness set by constructing
a
a system where
the the intersection is an irreducible
component and the basic idea is this if
the witness points are generic which
they are with probability one
then the jacobian matrix j f of a jf of
b evaluated at that at a witness point
has the generic rank the same rank as
as almost all points on the set
so i can append
the con algebraic condition that this is
the rank of the set i'm looking for to
the original equations
and now i have a new set of equations
that's the old ones plus this rank
condition
and then you iterate
on that if that
new system isn't you know you can test
is it does it suffice if it doesn't you
take the rank again and you go again all
right this is uh
what we call isosingular deflation this
applying this rank condition is a little
different than the deflation
method that it's built on top of the one
that
from lykan verskeldi
there's an e there
and jiao
that that was the first
uh deflation shown to
to terminate and it it's useful in in a
lot of areas but to get what we need
here we had to to
do this uh
variant on it that will will work in
this context and we call it iso singular
deflation
because we're looking essentially for
the points that all have the same kind
of singularity that's why we call it iso
singular
now
how do we compute all these things so
regeneration
is uh something that will allow us to
compute
a intersect v of f for some new f
without first decomposing v of f
and this is something we've had out for
just a few years i'll give you a little
view of that
so
suppose we're back to solving a system
f1 through fn and suppose at some stage
we've
gotten all the isolated points that's
what i mean by v sub zero all the
isolated points of f one through f k
minus one intersected with some generic
linears
okay
and what i wanna go to in the basic step
of regeneration is replacing this linear
with the next function in the system
and it's fairly simple to do this
we can do a continuation where we move
the coefficients of this linear to other
values so we can we can produce the
intersection with any number of
different linear general linear
equations
if we do that
dk times where that's the degree of the
next
function
then we can take the union of all these
solution points and that will be the
solution
to this system
now i've managed to replace
a single linear with something that is
degree
decay
and then i just do a linear homotopic to
the new
f that's the process we call
regenerations pretty pretty simple idea
and then if you want to solve the whole
system you just repeat that
the interesting thing about regeneration
is that if
if this subset of systems has any kind
of special character things going off to
infinity going into singularities and so
on and you're not interested in
singularities you get to throw all that
away and it simplifies the process as
you go forward
as opposed to
something like the total degree that
shoots for the whole thing at once
do you also get to exploit the last few
linears have a dimension reduction
i mean the last few linear state linear
conditions they define a smaller
dimensional yeah oh yeah explain that as
well yes so um it there's a kind of a
trade-off between
moving the the coordinates in that
subspace
versus uh having reduced this the
subspace so we do a little analysis
sometimes we move to coordinates on the
subspace sometimes we keep the original
coordinates and you can do a calculation
which has fewer
operations potentially this allows you
to investigate things of low code
dimension very efficiently
yes
without having to worry about the full
dimension yes
so
we have all these pieces around i've
described some of them to you so let's
look at at a a variant of the problem
suppose we have
a and b witness sets for them and we
bring in a new system f so this is the
kind of thing we have
in the old days we used to just start
with the system and we're interested in
its solution set but in this in this
newer world we want to do
look at this look at that now look at
the intersections bring in new things
that gives you a lot more flexibility
about how you can get to the final thing
that you're you're interested in okay so
suppose i have
a sets a and b around and i want to
throw in a new system
and compute this intersection so what
we're going to do to uh is a
generalization of the diagonal homotopic
so remember to do the diagonal homotope
we had a and b and c n and we wanted the
intersection and we moved it to
computing this instead up in c n cross c
n okay
the the new idea is that we can do
basically the same thing but we just
replace the diagonal v of x minus y with
this v of f that we want to intersect
with
and it's even possible for f to bring in
new variables which is often quite
uh
an interesting thing to do
and i'll just mention that this kind of
problem if i want to say suppose i want
to test suppose i have set a and i want
to test if x naught is in a
one way to do that is to intersect a
with just this variety
and if that's
non-empty
then it means that x naught is
in the variety and it turns out that if
you do our new procedure posing this
problem to it what comes out is
something that we were already doing
called the homotope membership
test so it's kind of nice that
everything
ties together
so how does the new procedure work
step one is to use the witness sets for
a and b
to get a witness set for a cross b and c
n and that's a that's in
basically you're moving from
linears in the two
cns to linears on the c2n so it's just a
simple
uh
process of moving coefficients of linear
equations around
once you have this linear equations
you can regenerate a randomization of f
equation by equation what do i mean by a
randomization if you have more equations
than the code dimension that you're
cutting out
if you take a random combination of the
polynomials you'll preserve
that set and so you can you can compute
on that instead
then once you have
regenerated f
you'll have witness points and again we
have to use iso singular deflation
to get our
our witness system and then an optional
fourth step would be decomposing this
into its irreducible components
which i haven't told you how we do but
i'm not going to tell you today if you
want to ask me we can talk about that
i want to move on now and talk a little
bit about computing real algebraic sets
and like i said before there's another
talk on this today
so i'm going to give you just
the
10 000 foot views
they like to say in industry
and let's talk
start by talking about projections and
cell decomposition
so
let
let a be an irreducible algebraic set of
dimension d and multiplicity 1.
that's where i'm going to start from
if i have some set a with multiplicity
greater than one i can reduce to this by
replacing a
by what i just write as iso of a this is
the iso singular deflation of a
it's
actually
this this procedure is not the nicest
one so it is kind of a limiting factor
in what you can do practically i'll i i
want to make that clear but in principle
it can always be done
with enough computation
so we can say that a is multiplicity one
and let
this be the witness set for a and now
let's assume that f a is real meaning
that it maps real points to real points
so the coefficients of the polynomials
are real
and we want to find a intersect the
reals
so we have this witness set
on complex space and we'd like to know
something about the real points in there
so let pi be a linear projection from c
n to c d remember d
is the dimension of a
okay for as a risky open subset of c d
the a intersect the fiber over x
consists of degree
a
isolated non-singular points
right
this
hole still holds if my projection is a
real one
so i have some projection onto real rd
above a point in there i get some number
of intersections
over the complexes they'll still be
degree a of them
but over the reals
some
less than or equal to degree a of them
will be real okay
and
now let's define the critical set of a
with respect to pi is this thing
i'm going to call it k
the critical set with respect to pi of a
is a intersect the variety of the
determinant
here this is our function f a our set of
polynomials this is the
uh the jacobian of the projection
the determinant equal to 0 means it's
singular and i have a intersect that and
then we'll just consider the real part
of that
so what is special about this this is a
necessary condition for the real root
count to change
okay it means that
two roots have come together or a set is
ending in a singular curve or something
like that okay so you being singular is
a is a condition for the number of real
roots to change so
if i'm down here
and here's the here's the critical set
if i have some open subset
that doesn't touch the critical set then
above the points in here i have these
nice sheets
i've got the implicit function theorem
that i've defined nice
patches above it some number of them are
real
and now i can move around in u and i can
con
by continuation compute other points on
these sheets and i'd like to just put it
together
so
to
describe real points in a it suffices to
decompose
rd take out the critical set into cells
and use continuation to determine two
things how the real patches meet each
other and how the real patches meet the
critical set
and then
i put a note here
some parts of the critical set might
have no patches meeting them
and an example of that if you're
familiar with
the so-called whitney umbrella it's this
nice surface and then coming out of it
is a singular line so you wouldn't have
any
of the of the surface patches meeting
this singular line but yet it's uh it's
part of the real uh set of solutions
so
uh
the these kind of things just like the
whitney umbrella if it's if it's if
nothing is meeting it it's a lower
dimensional singular set
and you and we can find those as well
because they'll be part of k
so here's a here's a illustration of
that suppose this is my curve
and i've picked a projection it projects
it's a curve so i'm projecting it on r1
and where the projection is basically
tangent
those will be critical points where the
curve crosses itself that's also going
to be a singularity i'll get a critical
point there in between the critical
points there's just nice arcs
and if i cut the curve in the middle
i'll get some set of points
and then i can by continuation
go to the critical points each direction
and see how the arcs meet up
see how they meet at the singular points
of the critical set as well and once you
have all of that you have a nice picture
of the whole
real curve
if you're
in if you have a surface
it's a little dicer because now i'm
projecting onto
two coordinates i get uh
the critical set will be a critical
curve
it's sort of the points upstairs that
make the edges of the shadow downstairs
and uh
then i have to carve up that
two-dimensional set down there into
cells but you do that by also then
decomposing the critical curve in the
reels
and so you get critical points along
that and that's how you start carving up
your cells downstairs i'm going to let
daniel
take you through more of that today
let's just say then that to find a
witness set for the critical set
we can use the intersection algorithm so
this is how some of this ties together
uh and one version instead of putting
the determinant to zero
i can say well let's take a tangent
vector i bring in a tangent space now i
have a cross p n intersected with this
and that is another way to describe the
critical set
uh
you after you're done you have to
project away the tangent space and you
have the critical set
so
we not only have to find the the
critical set but then if if uh
if k is higher dimensional we then have
to find a real cell decomposition of k
and it will also have its own critical
set if it's high enough dimension and
you have to kind of go down
so
uh if
if a is a curve
then like we saw in the previous
illustration k is just a set of points
and so the real points in k
are the end points of the cell
decomposition
if a is a surface then critical sets a
curve and we have to apply cell
decomposition to that so then we're
going to be looking at the critical set
of the critical set of something and
this is where the procedure starts to
get nasty
but
what we have at the current stage is a
complete algorithm for the curve case
and the surface case
and we have this burtini real project
that has code to do these things and
as i keep saying i'm going to let daniel
show you some really nice pictures and
describe this
but let's look now at applications i
think i'm doing okay
on time
uh this
first one i'd like to talk about is it's
connected to
back to this classic thing from
mechanics the four bar linkage
if you take a three bar
thing you'll make a rigid triangle we
build bridges out of that but then when
you want things to move you put in one
more link and now you've got a
quadrilateral and it can
you can move
and it's surprising
what mechanical engineers can do by
manipulating these these things to make
various devices so it's it's a classic
thing because
it's uh it's like a fundamental machine
element
there's different things you can do with
a four bar linkage and here here are the
some of the main ones one thing you
might do is what we call body guidance
so body guidance says
i've got some
some link
that i want to move to several different
positions
and i care not just about when i say
let's say poses
i care not just about position but also
orientation at each of these
so
for example
uh it could be the suspension of a car
and i care
not i i've got to allow the the tire to
bounce as you go over potholes but i
also care about its orientation as it
bounces you don't want it to wobble so
in fact
it's it's a subtle thing but exactly
how the orientation changes as it
bounces has a influence on how stable
the vehicle rolls so it's a it's kind of
a critical thing
you could also be opening the trunk
of your car and that's a link that moves
in space and you may specify a certain
kind of path you'd like that to take you
design a linkage to do that if you look
in the trunks of your car you will find
a mechanism there
some of them have a simple hinge
but a lot of them have a four bar
linkage or even a six bar sometimes
so body guidance
you specify poses position and
orientation for the coupler frame to
attain and there's a classic burmester
problem this is why we're calling these
burmester a guy back in 1888 came up
with solutions for when you give the
maximum number of poses
on the other end of the spectrum
is what we call path generation that's
like what i was saying over here where i
just give points that i want that point
that coupler point to go through and i
don't care what orientation it has when
it when it goes through it
so that's called path generation
and uh we ignore orientation
and uh the maximum number of points you
can give and still expect a solution is
nine and so i'll
uh put forward the nine point problem in
1923.
the newest thing that we started doing
just a little bit ago with the guys that
at
university dayton is what we call mixed
burmester where you specify some poses
in some positions
so you care
where
about orientation for some of the things
and then you just want to kind of return
any way possible through some other
positions and you don't care about the
orientation and the rest
uh these some terminology this is the
coupler point the coupler frame
this we call the circle point because
when the linkage move it moves on a
circle we call this a center point
because that one that point stays fixed
there okay
so what is the whole mixed burmester
family of problems
you can give up to nine points and up to
five
poses
uh you don't see nine points on here
because if you give only points you can
specify an orientation at one of them
for free so the nine point problem in
this chart is really the one pose eight
point problem so it sits here
and this is the dimension of the set you
expect for gen for general
data
so if i give you general
uh eight points in one pose i expect a
zero dimensional solution set if i only
gave you seven points here instead you
expect a curve of solutions and so on up
the scale and
burmester
work these two problems where you have
the maximum number of poses or
just four and you expect to have
it's interesting the the problem
decomposes
let me go back
if you give
if you give all poses you can look at
the two sides independently because
they're only kind of uh coupled together
through the orientation part
and so that's what makes uh these
problems easy this is a two-dimensional
set but it's really a one-dimensional
set cross itself you can solve for the
curve and you've got it so that's what
burmester did
and up here is alts problem is posed in
first solved by continuation in 1992
by
wampler and those guys
uh
here's the chart
and these numbers in here uh i'll give
credit to john he he generated all of
these looking at the dimension at the
degree of the solution set in each of
these cases
so here's the the result from 1992
there's 86 52 solutions here turns out
when you give all points there's uh an
order six
symmetry group goes on so there's like
the 1442 this divided by six really
distinct
solutions taking out the symmetries
that symmetry doesn't apply anywhere
else
in uh in the diagram
so
for so we we list the 86 52 not the 1442
here for comparison
an interesting one that we looked at a
little more you get three points and
three poses this is a curve of degree
362.
and here's a picture of it so
i'll just point out one thing if i'm if
i want to do
this curve
the one way to sample this curve is to
take the third point
and and turn it into a pose so move to
the two fourths
space by giving an orientation at that
third point
and then
try a bunch of different orientations at
each one i'll have 60 solutions and then
you can plot those
so then you get a picture like this
where the points aren't you don't know
how they connect to each other you've
sampled essentially this curve by that
means and this is what the guys first
did down at university dayton
we take our
our uh real decomposition approach to
this
and we can turn that picture
into this picture where we really do
have all of the arcs we know exactly
where
anything ends and turns and and how it
all fits together
so it's kind of
kind of cool
it's not that easy to do a degree 362
curve
if you don't believe me i encourage you
to try it yourself
uh here's an here's another one
and uh and and daniel did this one it's
a it's another 3-3 burmester curve if
you zoom way out
you see the asymptotes that go off to
infinity you cannot you you could
compute those directly by intersecting
the curve with a plane at infinity and
you'd see where you expect these to go
to
but there's something interesting going
on down in here so let's zoom in
and it's looking kind of knotty and
let's zoom in again
and it's looking
pretty interesting
and uh one thing that you see in this
plot and this by the way is the
projection
onto the center point
i believe it's a center point not the
circle point
if you
and so these are all the designs that
meet the specification
and this is in the plane
where does where can this point be
and it can be at any of these points and
you pick one of these and the rest of
the of the mechanism is determined and
it's interesting there's something going
on here here and here
and if you plot that as a triangle
it turns out this is
what we call the pole triangle for the
three poses and what's a pole triangle
if i give you two poses
then
on the perpendicular bisector of these
if i put a link here i can take this
point to this point right
by rotating
and somewhere along here
if this
is the
angle of rotation somewhere along here
the angle between these is also theta
so it not only takes that point to that
point but it takes this frame to this
frame that's the pole of the two frames
we had three
frames in the specifications so there's
three poles
and this is where those poles are
so
that was an unexpected result that if
you project this high degree thing
onto the circle point coordinates that
these poles would show up and then even
more interesting and i said well daniel
tell me where these points are he said
well upstairs where i'm doing the
computation nothing crosses it's only in
the projection that they cross so it's
kind of a surprising thing and
the
mechanical engineers that at dayton said
they were the ones that figured out what
this triangle really means
okay and then for the
rest of the time we're going to talk
about spear packings if nobody has any
any questions
oh
let's uh let's let's look at this sphere
packing problem
and again at this table of new seeds
what is the problem
determine all rigid packings of inner
fewer identical spheres and why is it
interesting
this models how spheres immersed in the
liquid form into colloidal mixtures of
particle clusters so if we model this as
hard spheres with short range attraction
then they're basically going to stick to
each other and the centers will be
at the distance of twice the radius or
the diameter of the spheres
so if we know a complete list of the
packings we can determine the energies
of each packing
and then predict clustered
uh distribution so if you if you put
the n spheres in solution and wait for
them to come to a
cluster
they'll distribute according to the
energies of the various clusters
uh and as i mentioned earlier
vinnie monaharan at harvard actually
runs experiments so you can you can go
back from the math predictions and and
see if it's predicting what the physics
uh
experiment actually shows
and uh
one of the interesting things is that
this
opens the possibility of designing
colloids or for micro manufacturing of
desired clusters by mixing spheres with
different dna coatings so if you make it
so that not all the spheres i are
identical but they they stick to each
other preferentially in certain patterns
you can try to make a system where you
just
put the spheres in solution you wait for
them to come together and they'll be in
the in the shape that you wanted
so
let's take on this problem of
determining all packings of size
less than or equal to n
so
one of the steps is to enumerate all
non-isomorphic minimally rigid adjacency
matrices a what is a adjacency matrix
it's one that has a
a
a sub i j is one if sphere i touches
sphere j and it's zero otherwise it's
just one way of encoding what is the set
of contacts
uh non-isomorphic means
you can renumber the spheres and get a
different ai that means the same thing
so we want to we don't want to redo that
problem we want to find just the
non-isomorphic ones
and then what does minimally rigid mean
it means it has exactly three n minus
six contacts for n spheres
where does that come from
well each
each sphere has three coordinates
and then if we've constrained by this
many i'll have six degrees of freedom
left
which is the degrees of freedom of a
rigid body
it can
translate with three degrees of freedom
rotate with three degrees of freedom so
if you have three n minus six contacts
you're in this what we call minimally
rigid situation
and
so you can start enumerating under these
conditions but you can also prune by
certain impossibility rules so
if i have
two spheres in contact
and i ask the question how many spheres
can i put in
here that's kind of that are contacting
both of them
then you can get at you can fit at most
five in there so that's an example of a
limit so uh
a adjacency matrix that had
six spheres in contact with both a and b
that they contact each other you know is
impossible you don't have to consider
that
there's a couple other rules of that
sort that can help prune the problem
down
okay let's say you can do that and you
can enumerate those that's a that's a
problem in in graph theory
uh for each one of the a's that's left
over we have to solve a system of
distance equation
we want to find all the isolated
real roots and it's not necessarily a
unique answer
and not all of the answers are
um are of interest so here's an example
suppose i have this set of
of
it's easier to look at the spheres
shrunk down
and then draw a link of the ones that
are contacting so you can see through
the figure and see what's contacting
what so each one of these represents the
sphere
in the real thing you would you would
grow these till they touch right
so this is a good packing because all of
the contacts that are specified are
satisfied and no sphere that's not
contacting
is closer than the diameter distance
here these
this arrangement it satisfies all the
specified distances but you can see that
some of them are too close so if i
started expanding these spheres to their
true size these spheres are interfering
with each other
so you find all the isolated real
solutions you call out any that have
inner penetrating spheres and then an
interesting thing to do is detect what
they call chiral pairs basically if you
take the mirror image all the distances
are preserved the mirror image is could
be this the the thing back again or it
could be
uh a chiral pair where it's a different
it's the mirror image is different than
the original
so
if you're going to do all of that it's a
pretty big program to try to try to
solve all of them and one of the
interesting things is that you don't
need to solve
every packing from scratch
you can decompose them into a series of
previously solved
sub problems and we call these packing
rules so
each of the
sub problems is a parameterized
polynomial system
and after solving a rule for generic
parameters
subsequent appearances of the rule can
be solved via parameter continuation
this will become a little more clear in
another slide
so the packing rules can be represented
by a kinematic type graph
and what i'm going to show you next is
some of these so here's my here's my
notation there's two types of nodes in
these graphs
one is p for a point or r for a rigid
body so a rigid body stands for some
collection of spheres that have
are
uh rigid with respect to each other they
have enough contacts that they become a
rigid body
and then i have three types of edges in
my graph charles johnson as a question
two minutes two minutes
ah okay
somehow i i was hitting a different
target okay
we have simple contacts
we can share a sphere between two rigid
bodies or we can share a pair of them so
we have like an edge
and this gives you this minimally rigid
uh
rules and
here is
the the chart from the original one by
arcus where they have
here's how many
adjacency matrices how many
non-isomorphic ones they are
it's uh not nearly as bad as this but
it's still pretty bad
uh but then the minimally rigid ones
grows a little slower and then the
iterative ones is most of those and by
iterative
uh she means that you can get it by just
two rules a tetrahedron rule which i'll
describe in a second or just gluing two
rigid bodies together on a triangle and
this is the leftover ones what she
called non-iterative you can see it's
starting to grow at n equals 10 and it's
going to grow much faster after that
so here's the kind of rules
the tetrahedron rule is i have a point
with three contacts so that points
position will be determined either here
or mirror image below so it has two
roots but we have other ways for example
if i take two rigid bodies with six
contacts between them uh those who have
heard some of my previous talks that's
equivalent to what we do in kinematics
called a stuart goth platform where
there's two platforms and six legs
uh it has at most 40 routes
and there's various other examples
so each roll gives one or more solutions
and then you that would be a rigid body
that you can build bigger things out of
and uh the vast majority of big in
packings have at least one rigid sub
packing and so you you work your rules
up that way
so let's wrap up
numerical algebraic geometry point out
the witness sets of the fundamental
construct
irreducible decomposition is key even
though i didn't tell you how to do it
today
and
software is pertinee and open source
free thing
intersection algorithms we're able to do
further investigation on sets
represented by witness sets
regeneration is one of our most
effective approaches in this
and we need this thing called
isosingular theory to complete some of
the singular cases
and then when we do cell decomposition
of real algebraic sets
as a way of building a complete map of
the real set how everything connects
together uses intersection and iso
singular deflation
and limited at present to curves and
surfaces
and i've talked about a couple of
application areas of robot mechanisms
and sphere packing
any questions
yes does your robot have some kind of
learning algorithm so it knows how to
move
uh you mean robonaut yeah well yeah
there's
it can be operated several ways it has
autonomous modes there's uh there's
cameras in the head that's why it has a
head so there's a vision system
um so
they have routines for doing some of
these things like finding a button and
pushing it you know that's completely
autonomous there's another mode where
a person can look through the eyes of it
and control it
remotely
the learning aspect there is a a little
start on that i'd say it's not very far
yet
there's a lot of learning going on on
the people involved
yes
when you solve this
matrix adjacency
yep in addition to the real roots yes
yeah yeah definitely so you know there's
a whole other class of algorithms
which if you want to work just on the
reels you can do these exclusion box
cutting methods that's another way to
come with these problems
um
we're we're coming from this angle but
that's another way you can go when it
gets high dimensional
the the cutting
routine there's a lot of dimensions to
cut in
so um
it's not clear
if there are no real solutions often the
the exclusion method can conclude that
pretty quickly
if if there are though then it might
work a long time to find them so these
are some of the things it might be that
uh
checking quickly are there any
you know to some resolution before you
go do the homotopy you know you could
put things together likewise
yeah i i have a question uh uh about the
weaknesses so you you use those to find
components of positive dimension yes um
can you also handle the case when uh
there are components of uh various
dimensions yes yeah basically you uh the
way the algorithms work is they test at
every possible dimension and so you
you cut with with something of code
dimension one and you see if anything is
there then you you cut with code
dimension two and see if anything's
there and so on work your way down the
possibilities and at each level
you're looking for isolated roots that
you've sliced out there so you know
you're in business there actually are
these cascade methods that use the
result at one dimension to feed the next
dimension so they're they can be a
little more efficient than just starting
over from scratch at each dimension
right
well your routinely reel seems to have
some functionality of other approaches
that's probably like like like um
central african culture composition yeah
american numeric methods i think like
other collaborators have worked on that
i think
there is
any
contamination your performance and how
is it compared to these other methods i
would say it's a it's you know it's a
it's a maturing technology i think we're
getting to the point where
it might be worthwhile to to do some
runoffs to see you know up to this point
we've been
making sure our algorithms are are
correct and running reasonably efficient
you know no reason to do a
uh a runoff until you're you're kind of
at that stage so i would well i don't
have an answer now on how they compare
they're obviously the cylindric algebra
algebraic decomposition is quite closely
related to this but though
in in concept but in the details of what
you compute they're quite
different you know i just the question
is because i was wondering if you're
aware of all that other work oh yeah
yeah i'm aware of it
you know another problem with doing
comparison is that you have to somebody
has to get to be an expert in the other
things so they can run it and
you know until the software gets to a
level where
where idiots can run both and then see
how they come out you know it's hard to
compare
that's mike what do you do in one of
these cases where you've got
exponentially many isolated real roots
all degenerate
uh i work really hard
yeah there's no good answer
so the related question is
what sort of guarantee does virginia
give about
approximate correctness of the answers
that it does produce so in particular i
can easily easily code up integer linear
zero one integer linear programming
in in polynomial system solving so if i
do that if i in other words if i encode
a hard combinatorial problem
inside bertini does it give me bogus
answers because then that's not
it'll be more helpful if it says oh
sorry i don't know as opposed to giving
bogus answers which would be you know
you know then somebody has to go in
well um
how to answer that we do
use floating point there is the
possibility that when you track a path
you could cross paths or something we
make our algorithms
highly reliable we have
ways of testing are we carrying enough
digits and so on but it's not a it's not
a perfect guarantee there is stuff out
there for
uh
for
guaranteeing that that you have taken
small enough steps that you don't cross
any paths unfortunately this is the
alpha theory this can be used for that
for example
unfortunately it's too expensive to to
carry it out that way so so we take a
more practical route you can if you have
a non-singular isolated route that you
have an approximation to you can use the
alpha theory to certify that that really
is
near an actual route
unfortunately if it's a singular route
you there's not a good method for that
that i know of
other
questions all right let's thanks charles